i told my psychiatrist everything
for the first time and
you know he was like he was like you
know
yeah he said you know he said um you
know um
you'll ruin him well and um you've got
this
this diagnosis schizoaffective disorder
i kind of thought my life was over as
soon as i got that diagnosis
[Music]
i wasn't like all the other kids do i
mean um
my parents they they took me to this
child psychologist when i was five
i was hearing things that weren't there
and yeah
um my behavior was becoming really
i was just becoming really withdrawn i
was i was i was quite violent as well
and yeah i spent i spent most of my sort
of yeah childhood
teenagers just thinking that i was
weird yeah and basically yeah when i was
10
i i saw the the film the truman show
with jim carrey
and uh i got into my head that i was in
my own version of
the truman show i would be like thinking
of you know sometimes
you might think of a person and then
that person would be there like walking
down the school corridor
and i'd be like yeah they're in my head
they you know they're playing with me i
thought i knew where the cameras were
they would watch me it's horrible it's
it's like
i'm desperate to get out of it because i
i just think
that you know there's cameras watching
me and everyone's an actor
and nothing's real no one's real and
yeah that's really horrible so in my mid
teens
this voice that i was hearing changed
and it became what i thought was the
devil
i guess what you know what really scares
me is just how like
where these things sort of come from and
how quickly they can
like envelop develop me when i was like
alone in my bedroom and
uh sometimes this voice would be
relentless
it was because i was struggling with my
sexuality and you know coming from a
religious jewish
family going to a jewish school i was
told being gay is a sin
so i didn't tell you i didn't talk about
it i didn't tell anyone um
i wanted i wanted everyone to think that
i was doing all right on the outsides
but i said i kept on saying to myself
you know what it's fine it's going to
pass i'm going to go to university
and that's going to solve everything
because like the fourth day of freshers
week
oh i just completely came crashing down
and i was like oh my god i haven't left
any of this behind
first time that i um i sort of tried to
explore my sexuality
and uh i got with i got i got with the
guy um i then had a psychotic episode
uh afterwards believed i was being
possessed uh
by the devil um and i couldn't control
anything what was going on my body and
what i was saying i ended up on the
streets
um like screaming and shouting and not
being able to control
any any anything any any part of me
which is horrible
i i was desperate at this point to be
admitted to hospital
and so at that point i finally
uh broke down to my parents um
and anyway and and
and as soon as i broke down to my
parents they took me to their
doctor and my doctor referred me
straight to a psychiatric hospital
and yeah that i was i was admitted
straight away and given this diagnosis
and i guess that was the start of um
my stay in this in this psychiatric
hospital
i told my psychiatrist everything for
the first time and
you know he was like he was like you
know
yeah he said you know he said um you
know um
you'll ruin him well and um you've got
this
this diagnosis schizophrenic disorder
this form of schizophrenia
and um
i just it was yeah it was a massive
shock because
i mean schizophrenia everything i
thought about
schizophrenia was i guess like from the
media and that was all
people with schizophrenia were dangerous
and violent and um
i just i couldn't i really couldn't take
it in for a long time this diagnosis it
took me years to
deal with it to be honest because uh i
kind of thought my life was over as soon
as i got that diagnosis
i didn't know who i was anymore really
you know all the things i wanted to do
in life
don't know i just felt like they were
now all close to me because of this
diagnosis
so to be honest
there was only one option that was
suicide for me because
i yeah i wasn't going to live with this
diagnosis and
i could i couldn't i couldn't live with
the diagnosis and i couldn't
i couldn't be myself being being gay i
couldn't be myself in a really
a religious like sort of community so
i made a plan in my head and ran away
said
i said i needed a cigarette to the nurse
that was
on duty and she let me out basically i
ended up on
on on the edge of a bridge for me i
wasn't on
on on this bridge for very long when
this stranger basically came and he
stood next to me and he started to talk
to me
whenever i tried to talk about my
suicidal thoughts and feelings in
hospital
people were like right medication now
medication
back to the suicide ward but this guy
like on the bridge was just so oh you're
right mate like just i don't know i
hadn't
i hadn't had that yeah like human
interaction for a long time and
there was something about him he was
just so um
like you know grounded and and and
composed and like
open and he didn't want to basically
didn't want to run away from it didn't
want to shy away from what was going on
in my head
there was a couple of things that you
said that like got through and the first
thing was he said um he said don't be
embarrassed
um which i wish i just i needed to hear
that from someone you know don't be
embarrassed don't be ashamed
and the second thing that he said and
and the thing that
i think really sort of hit him he said
to me
he'd be all right mate you know you'd be
all right um which
might sound very simple but i needed
i needed to hear that from someone i
didn't believe that i'd be all right
and i don't think anyone around me did
so i don't know
this for this stranger just to
like put his faith in me yeah i think
that
i think that changed wow that changed my
outlook on
that on that day
i guess that was the very start of like
a long
long long journey to
dealing with it for me now
i was diagnosed when i was 20 i'm 33 now
and
i've had quite a few relapses and had to
go back into hospital
particularly in the last few years but i
guess now
i know like what to do i know i know
when i need help that's the thing i know
when i need help and i know
to ask for it now i'm i'm really lucky
i've got
amazing family and friends like support
network and and i can i can be open and
it's hard i'm not gonna i'm gonna
i'm not gonna sugarcoat it it's hard you
know
basically i always try and compare it to
physical health so you know if i was to
have a heart attack
right now like i know that i wouldn't
hesitate to
get help i wouldn't and i guess if i
could
you know go back and like talk to my
sort of 15 year old self i'd say
it's just human what what what's going
on and what will happen is just human
i really thought i'd never be able to
like experience moments of
yeah like moments of like real happiness
like real like real
real real happiness like real joy like
real sort of love of life i never
thought i'd be able to
yeah reach those those moments but i
have
you